who knows what will happen after after
my fight if I have free time and you
know it's Hollywood and and anything can
happen
love seems to be happening for Jake Paul
the youtuber it's fresh off his boxing
match win against anundson Gibbs and
he's spending time with a new boo on
Thursday Jake posted this photo
kissing model Julia Rose on the cheek he
captioned it quote bro so what he also
took a sexy video of the model as they
enjoyed a day on the water together
Julia who was also a social media star
it's known for her time on the MTV
dating series are you the one I don't
like
explicit people she's also known for
being the woman who flashed a stroke
pitcher Gerrit Cole at the 2019 World
Series
Julia also made a cameo in Jake's music
video for these days pick up et has
reached out to the youtuber for comment
meanwhile fans are connecting the dots
after the two were spotted hanging
together in Miami just over a week ago
for Jake's big fight but get this
Santa mojo was also in Miami and based
off of her Instagram she also enjoyed
spending time with the couple
she even teamed up with Julia to stage a
fight in prank Jake
giulia captured the moment with Tana and
posted this pics Instagram simply saying
close so this happened Tana mojo was
Jake's last high-profile relationship
and it was a bit of a whirlwind the two
took it as far as having a Vegas wedding
five months later they decided to split
I love him I always will love him and if
it's meant to be it will be you know
what I mean but if it's not then it's
like I'm not gonna try to force
something that isn't there for the both
of us you know last month et spoke with
Jake about his feelings towards Tina
moving forward I always loved her you
know I think we're just better off as
friends when when we kind of made that
decision it was like a weight lifted off
of both of our shoulders and it kind of
reminded us like how the relationship
started which was friends and you know
she's an amazing girl it just wasn't the
right right time for us and we both have
things to focus on and you know we're
working on certain things together as
well so it's it's great that we're still
able to you know have a great amazing
relationship
[Music]